[Music]
greetings to my 3abn family and welcome
to another 3abn today Bible Q&A I'm
Ricky Carter I'll be your host today
we've got another hour pack program with
your Bible questions we've got the
answers right here in the word of God
and our panelist sitting right next to
me are going to be the ones who will be
answering those questions so let me
introduce you to them to my right is
Sister Shelley Quinn welcome sister
thank you it's always such a joy to be
here and we want to thank you for
sending in your questions CU we love
researching the answers amen and then
next to her we have Pastor Daniel morone
welcome brother thank you for having me
and thank you that you guys have tuned
in to watch today thanks for your
questions amen and then right next to
him via Skype we have Pastor James rafy
welcome
brother thank you Ricky good to be here
with you and Shelley and Daniel looking
forward to the questions that are coming
in it's such a blessing to be part of
the group amen amen well before we get
started we want to ask the Lord to be
with us as we read his word so Pastor
morone could you give us a prayer please
absolutely thank you Father in Heaven
Lord we are so grateful to you for
giving us your
word to help us to comfort us to
strengthen us encourage us and to bless
us thank you for these questions pray
for your Holy Spirit to be here as we
open your word together in Jesus name
amen amen amen amen well before I ask
the first question let me remind you at
home how you can participate
you can participate in one of three ways
you can email us your questions to Bible
QA 3ab m.tb that's Bible QA 3abn.org
sister shelle I've got your first
question you ready I'm ready all right
when Jesus Christ nailed the sacrificial
system on the cross did that include the
tithing system too that's from Joseph in
Arizona who texted that to us Joseph
thank you for that question if you want
a complete answer you can go online and
watch uh 3 amen Worship Hour that I did
called should Christians tithe it's a
whole hour on this but let's go through
this quickly the Old Testament
sacrificial system the feast days and
all of these things were symbolize
Christ Ministry and they were nailed to
the cross they ended at the cross but
God's system of tithing was not included
in that sacrificial system the
dedication of the tenth was sacred to
God and we find it well before the time
of Moses well before the the time of the
old Covenant in Genesis 14 we see it was
practiced by Abraham he presented a
tithe of all of his War booty to the
king of Jerusalem who was also called
the priest of the most high and then we
see that Jacob who was the son of Isaac
he also this would be the grandson of
Abraham as an exile and a fugitive he
pledged to offer God a tithe if he would
of all of his possessions if God would
bring him back safely in Genesis 28:22
he says of all that you give me I'll
surely give a tenth to you well before
the time of Moses in the old Covenant
but now when Israel was established as a
nation after their release from Egypt
God reaffirmed the system of tithing it
was a divine
institution and he told them their
prosperity actually depended on their
obedience to that during the reign of
King Hezekiah when there was a great
Reformation of worship guess what the
first thing the people did we see it in
second chronicles 315 and 6 they eagerly
brought their tithe so tithing
reinforced their Covenant relationship
with God showing that actually they were
it was a Tang ible expression of their
faithfulness and commitment the New
Testament is merely a continuation of
The Narrative of the Old Testament it's
all the same story and the New Testament
Christians guess what scriptures they
used the Old Testament what we look at
so the New Testament assumes the
validity of tithing as a Divine
Institute of worship no New Testament
writer relaxes its obligation Jesus
approved of upholding it see that in
Matthew
23:23 Paul calls the patriarch Abraham
the father of all in Romans 4:16 and we
see in Hebrews chapter 7 especially
Abraham is set forth as an
example of tithing and so this somewhat
casual reference to tithing shows that
it was already an established custom in
the Christian church at that early date
amen amen thank you very much sister
quick correction mesc was king of Salem
and priest of most high god oh okay
thank you for that correction all right
Pastor morone here's your first question
I thoroughly enjoy Christmas however as
I learn more about the Pagan history of
the evergreen tree I'm conflicted about
how to celebrate and continue to create
family traditions during the season how
can we celebrate Christmas without
submitting to Pagan Traditions but still
create memories with family should I
just replace it with one of the feasts
that's from cassia in Alabama who
emailed that to us all right well thank
you cassia for sending that in I'm sure
other people wonder the same thing it's
true that the Evergreen was used by the
pagans in their Heathen ceremonies and
celebrations but it's also true and
interesting that the Christians use them
also it the Evergreen symbolized
Eternal you Jeremiah 10 3-9 a lot of
or some I should say Christians use
those texts to uh say that we shouldn't
have a Christmas tree so uh let's just
go over that with with you here and
starting with verse two learn not the
way of the Heathen and be not dismayed
at the signs of Heaven that would be
like astrology for the Heathen are
dismayed by them here's verse three for
the customs of the people are vain for
one cutteth a tree out of the forest the
work of the hands of the workmen that
word Workman is actually a fabricator of
any type of material with the axe and
verse four they deck it with silver and
with gold they fasten it with nails and
with hammers and it moves not they are
upright that word upright that's
actually could be hammered or molded by
hammering or out of one piece of any
kind of material so you can see somebody
take a chainsaw you may have seen them
with with the art that they do or you
can see the totem poles made out of a
piece of wood and they make it look like
all kinds of interesting things but it
says that they can't go you know they
have to be carried you know they might
put legs on this like an idol and but it
won't go anywhere and it says Be not
Afraid of them for they cannot do evil
neither can they do any good then
Jeremiah contrasts the true God in
verses 6 and 7 then we read back in 8
verse 8 that they are all together
brutish and the word for that could be
to Kindle or consume by fire and they're
foolish or we could say silly you know
it's kind of silly this piece of wood
now you're worshiping this piece of
wood or it
says is a Doctrine which would be the
word reproof of vanity so he's scolding
them or emptiness which is transitory or
unsatisfactory and then verse 9 keeps on
talking about the Craftsman making an
idol so it doesn't appear that the
Bible's actually condemning the use of a
tree at Christmas time though anything
actually can become an idol numbers 219
we see that the Brazen serpent that
Moses was told to make and have those
that were bitten by the poisonous snake
to look at it and to live the Israelites
were um eventually be it became an idol
if you look at 2 Kings 18:4 they were
worshiping this now so they had to get
rid of that so you take away our
takeaway would be to regarding trees or
anything else to not worship that what's
created but the Creator so Casia I love
your idea of creating family traditions
and I believe keeping things simple and
having and showing that love for each
other like Jesus did when he was here uh
on this Earth and you want your family
to remember that love that you guys
shared with each other you know when I
recall the time in our home we remember
the love back in those holiday times the
Christians that I excuse me the
Christmases that I remember most were
the simple ones I remember uh one year
we didn't have a lot of money so we just
put our names in a hat we each picked a
name out you picked your own name you
had to put it back in the Hat but then
we each bought each other one gift for
that Christmas and then I remember
stringing popcorn for the tree and then
also making paper chains and it was a
fun those are the things that I remember
about Christmas time so again cassia
blessings on you and your Traditions
amen thank you what chapter in Jeremiah
Was that again it was uh
30 or 1039 339 10 339 great thank you
very much sir all right Pastor James
here's your first question
if someone is ignorant of the truth and
lives a worldly life will they be saved
if so at what point is someone no longer
ignorant is it just hearing about God or
hearing the entire truth that we as
Seventh Day Adventist believe I've heard
people say that if someone is saved in
their ignorance then why should we tell
them the truth when they could then be
lost because of that how should I answer
this type of question that's from Warren
in California who emailed that to us
thank you for this question Warren you
know it's a very important one as it
pertains to Salvation the salvation of
people who may be ignorant of Jesus and
the way of Salvation so a key issue to
address here is what kind of Life are
people living who are in ignorance of
the truth now Romans chap 2: 14-6 are
Bible texts which will help us to
understand that God will save people who
may not be familiar with the truth as
you noted but who live more lives that
are in harmony with God's Ten
Commandment law let's look here in
Romans Chapter 2 beginning with verse 14
it says for when the Gentiles that's
people who don't necessarily believe God
or follow God which have not the law do
by Nature the things that are contained
in the law these having not the law are
a law unto themselves which show the
work of the law written in their hearts
their conscience also bearing witness
and their thoughts the meanwhile
accusing or excusing one another in that
day when God shall judge judge the
secrets of men by Jesus Christ according
to my gospel now there's a lot here to
consider there's a key phrase here and
it says the work of the law written in
their hearts now this phrase is actually
a description of the New Covenant
experience mentioned in the bible like
in Hebrews 8 6-12 and Ezekiel
36:26 and there are some other key words
too law for example mentioned five times
when describing these Gentiles and
conscience and judge and gospel in other
words these verses refer to the gospel
teaching that God through Christ is
going to judge the conscience of them
that by patient continuance in wello
seek glory and honor and immortality and
eternal life even though they don't know
God or the law so another scripture you
might want to refer to is acts 17 where
Paul is talking to the Greeks and the
worshippers of different gods and then
he introduced to them introduces to them
the unknown God they have a kind of a
place for them an idol for them and he
say says you know God is Not worshiped
with Idols but in your ignorance God
Winks but now that you know this he's
commanding you to repent because God has
appointed a day when he will judge the
world in righteousness by Jesus Christ
who he resurrected from the grave I'm
just summarizing all of that again we
have a judgment we have repentance which
is also mentioned in Romans 2 in the
context of verses 14 to6 the law is
alluded to calling Paul calling them not
to worship idols that's the you know
second commandment and first commandment
and also first and second commandment
also the Gospel of Jesus Christ which is
noted in the resurrection from the dead
so this means that it's best to
Enlighten people about Jesus and the
truth um even though God Winks at our
ignorance we can't just say well God
Winks at our ignorance so we shouldn't
Enlighten people about the truth in fact
in John chapter 3 we actually told that
it would be wrong for us to leave people
in darkness and that people who want to
stay in darkness are actually going to
come under God's condemnation in fact
the context of this is talking about
God's great love for the world so again
we have the gospel God so loved the
world that he gave his only begotten son
but notice what he goes on to say here
in verse 17 God didn't send his son to
condemn the world but that the world
through him might be saved but then in
verse 19 it says uh or verse 18 He that
believeth on him is not condemned but he
that believeth not is condemned already
because he has not believed in the name
of the only begotten Son of God and this
is the condemnation that light has come
into the world and Men love Darkness
rather than light because they're Deeds
are evil if you don't come to the light
because your Deeds are evil there is a
condemnation that comes upon us so
Warren we see a balance in the Bible yes
God will save people who do not know the
truth as we know the truth is the letter
of the law but God is not it's not safe
for us to stay away from the truth
because God Winks at our ignor you know
the light of Truth when it shines upon
our path we need to follow in that light
of Truth so that balance there God Saves
people in their ignorance but he also
enlightens them and calls them to
repentance I hope this is helpful amen
amen thank you very much sir all right
sister shelle here's your second
question can you please explain Exodus
33:1 and verse 19 is there a conflict
here or a mere difference in meaning
that's from Julie and Barbados who
emailed that to us oh Julie I get asked
this question all the time let's look at
this in context we're going to read
Exodus 3310 and 11 and it says all the
people saw the pillar of cloud standing
at the Tabernacle door this is after
they'd broken Covenant with God by
worshiping the idol and now they're not
building the sanctuary yet and Moses had
pitched his tent AAR out and he's
begging God to renew the Covenant and it
says the people saw the pillar of clouds
standing at the Tabernacle door that's
Moses tent and all the people Rose and
worshiped each man in his tent door so
the Lord spoke to Moses face to face as
a man speaks to his friend so in context
we see that God is speaking to Moses
from the pillar of cloud now when it
says face to face this is like a
conversation with a friend face to face
is merely a
figurative
expression to describe the Lord's direct
method of
communicating with Moses it wasn't
through dreams and Visions it wasn't
through a Medi an
intermediary and we know this because in
the very same passage as you point out
in Exodus
33:20 he says to Moses here he just got
through saying he's speaking face to
face with Moses but now he says to Moses
you cannot see my face for no man shall
see me and live so in verses 21- 23 the
Lord agreed that the next time Moses
came up the mountain he would show him
his glory he'd hide Moses in the cleft
of the rock put his hand over him so
Moses would only see his back not his
face and the bottom line is Moses was
always aware he practiced and walked in
the Divine awareness of God's presence
but he never saw his face amen good
answer thank you so much sister all
right Pastor morone here's your second
question all right could you kindly
explain Acts chapter 2 verse1 15 if in
Bible times the day began at sunset what
time was Peter referring to as to as 9
in the morning that's from Sicilia in
South Africa who emailed that to us well
thank you Cecilia for that
question let me read that for our
audience here acts
2:15 for these are not drunken as you
suppose seeing it's but the third hour
of the
day that's the King James version you
know the 12-hour clock it can be traced
back as far as Mesopotamia and ancient
Egypt both an Egyptian sundal for
daytime use and an Egyptian water clock
for night use were found in the Tomb of
pharaoh on men hotep I dating back to
1500 BC and these clocks divided their
respective times of use into 12 hours
each so the author of Acts most Scholars
attribute to Luke and he was going by
what the society went by in his day in
order for your audience or your readers
to understand what you're saying you
need to say it in a way that they can
comprehend what you're saying and so the
translators in your Bible that you used
they were using 6:00 a.m. at the sunrise
time so then seven would be the second
hour and then eight would be the I mean
first hour eight would be the second
hour the 9:00 a.m. would be the third
hour of the day which is what the King
James said that the third hour of the
day uh so they're not drunk basically I
remember working in the Fruit stand
there in Southern California when I was
about 14 years old and this guy was
always drunk by 11:00 he was the owner
of the Fruit Stand but anyway it wasn't
9:00 it was 11:00 and I you know if we
read it in the let's see but I see why
you're wondering as far as the way we
think you know man thinks from a
perspective of himself so he counts time
when he wakes up and I believe God
wanted us to see time from his
perspective so that we would remember
that we're just dust or created beings
and not Immortal you know Satan wants us
to forget God Pride was the downfall of
Satan and he's done a number on Humanity
deceiving us to think that we're
self-generated beings God wants us to
realize that we are dependent upon him
for life so when God created us he
started us out resting so when we read
in the Bible and the evening that's what
you're referring to and the morning were
the sixth day so maybe he was created at
the end of the sixth day and then and I
know that the we don't have any whether
people slept or not before sin I don't
really don't know but anyway somehow it
was rest and we rest in him as we begin
our day you know I know you no
conclusive evidence where they slept but
when God created man on the sixth day
his first full day of life started with
rest on the seventh day of creation when
God rested he Sanctified that day and he
blessed it so even though it was Man's
first full day of life he was to set it
aside for his work week and to rest to
remember he was created by God that's
why we have that I know mankind has
messed with God's reminder of his
creation and salvation by changing the
Sabbath from Saturday to Sunday that's
the way a lot of Christians are doing it
that way for from God's way to man's way
again I see pride getting in the way of
our recognizing our dependence upon God
and this carries over to Jesus's
sacrifice for us many people because of
Pride think there's something that they
can do to contribute to their salvation
when Jesus has paid it all and we just
need to accept it amen amen thank you
very much sir all
right Pastor James is your second
question
I heard a pastor recently say that if we
have to work on Sabbath it's okay
referring to people in health care
however he said the wages earned on
those days should be given to the Lord I
wish I had known this when I was working
as a hair stylist for 31 years I would
have done that since I was never able to
take Saturday off and that was the only
skill I knew to earn an income and pay
my mortgage it was a very challenging
time for me because I knew the Sabbath
was a day of physical rest I always
prayed asking God to show me a way out
and to have this day off but it never
happened does this only apply to health
workers or would that have applied to me
as well as a hair stylist that's from
Paula who emailed that to
us oh thank you for your question Paula
that's quite a uh history you've got
there and I really appreciate you just
wanting to find out more about this
question you know the idea of Health
Care Providers working on Sabbath is
actually based on a principle that's
found in both the Old Testament and the
New Testament and Jesus addresses this
when he's healing on the Sabbath day uh
Luke chapter 6 uh and if you look here
in verses 6 through1 of Luke chapter 6
you're going to find that Jesus
intentionally takes the Sabbath day on
the Sabbath day takes an opportunity to
heal a man's withered hand and he does
this to show that taking care of
essential Health needs of people is not
a violation of the Sabbath it is
something that we can do on the Sabbath
day and that's where we get the idea
that healthcare workers along with
others emergency crew workers you know
police officers firemen people who are
doing essential uh work essential duties
uh including myself I'm a pastor and and
the day that I work more than any other
day of the week is Sabbath I'm preaching
I'm teaching I'm doing Bible studies I'm
ministering to people and so the Sabbath
Jesus is emphasizing here the Sabbath
was made for man not man for the Sabbath
if God would have stopped providing for
us on the Sabbath what do you think
would happen so we see here a principle
and Jesus brings this out in a number of
places in the New Testament Luke 13 is
another place where he brings this out
and a lot of people try to take these
stories these illustrations where Jesus
heals on the Sabbath and they try to use
them to say that Jesus actually did away
with the Sabbath but nothing could be
further from the truth Jesus honored the
Sabbath and you know this principle can
be taken too far you know I was in
healthcare I was a healthcare worker in
a medical center when I became a
Christian and uh and an SDA and my job
was not an essential part of the lives
of patients I wasn't a nurse I wasn't a
doctor I wasn't in vital care so I
requested Sabbath off and I was able to
keep the Sabbath even though I work in a
hospital now most jobs do not even
qualify for Sabbath work because they're
not essential to life no working on the
Sabbath because they're not essential to
life so this Minister was probably
talking about people whose jobs qualify
in other words if they didn't do their
job someone would be hurt if they didn't
do their job someone might be injured
someone might lose their life and so
they need to be working sometimes on the
Sabbath and if that's what they do then
well they can take that money that they
earn and they can give that to the cause
of God so you know we lose a lot when we
work on the Sabbath and and you have
have a history of that and so many times
you know that can our faith but but God
can forgive us and he can restore what
the locusts have eaten so I I would
encourage you not to focus on what's
pasted but to make the most of the
sabbaths you now have to worship God to
fellowship with like Believers to
nurture faith and to nurture the faith
of others and to grow in Christ amen
amen thank you for that excellent answer
all right sister shelle before I give
you your third question let me remind
our viewers at home here's how you can
parti participate you can email your
questions to Bible QA
3abn.org
men all the rights Wana yes and thank
you so much for that question question
we know that the Bible tells us in
Genesis 127 that God created both Adam
and Eve in His image and in Genesis 2:18
it explains that Eve was created as the
helpmate for Adam now I want to look at
that Hebrew term there's two words in
the Hebrew it's ezer conecto the word
ezer has a profound meaning it signifies
strength support and it's used to
describe God as our helper in say Psalms
1:1 our helper in time of needs now the
word
cono is
uh it emphasizes mutuality and
partnership not hierarchy so together
these terms are showing that and
underscore that God's ideal design for
man and woman
were that they would be there would be
equality shared dignity and shared
responsibility between them Adam and Eve
were placed in a perfect environment in
the Garden of Eden and they shared
mutual respect everything was in Harmony
and they shared their responsibilities
but then with the entrance of sin it
upset the apple card it disrupted the
harmony it led led to the development of
a patriarchal society those became the
Norms inequality women were often uh
relegated to subordinate roles but here
when you say what did God do when this
happened God recognized women as
essential Amen to the stability and
prosperity of their families and
communities look at proverbs 31 The
Virtuous Woman Who contri rutes to her
family and does all of the wonderful
things with wisdom she's reflecting her
god-given
abilities and she's put up as a
something that we should praise now
God's love and his Justice and his Mercy
are evident in the Old Testament in his
the protection and rights that he
afforded women actually compared to
other patriarchal societies the Old
Testament laws provided women with
greater res uh leadership abil respect
they gave them leadership
responsibilities legal protections and
the women of Israel occupied roles that
women of other nations did not let me
look at a quick couple of things legal
protections for women we find marriage
and dowy laws in Exodus 22:16 and 17
safeguarded women's social standing and
their future security there were
inheritance rights like numbers 27 1- 11
that affirm the women's legal standing
as seen in the case of Zed's daughters
there was protection against abuse in
Deuteronomy 24 1-4 which ensured fair
treatment in marriage and and servitude
and women held leadership roles I think
of Miriam was a propheus Hala was a
propheus who guided King Josiah's Reign
Deborah was a judge and prophetess who
led Israel in spiritual and Military
matters Joel 2:28 and 29 prophesies that
God will pour His holy spirit out on men
and women showing that they shared they
share a role in God's Mission while the
Old Testament laws operated within the
patriarchal framework they reflected
God's
Redemptive purpose they s surpassed
cultural norms of the day pointing to
his Justice and compassion and they
provide a glimpse of God's more
inclusive system his vision of human
dignity and equality as is culminated in
the teachings of the New Testament amen
very good answer thank you so much all
right Pastor morone here's your third
question my son believed in Jesus but
used drugs he died of an
overdose I believe he may have had
ADHD and after his father died he was
depressed and got trapped in
addiction will he be saved because of
not
being not being in his right mind and
being lost in a addiction that's from
Carol who emailed that to
us Wow first of all Carol man my heart
goes out to
you you I've heard it said that to lose
a child is the worst thing that a parent
can go
through so I'm so very
sorry for the pain this has caused you
and I believe that God feels your pain
amen and his heart Grieves with your
heart he loves you and he loves your son
as well we are all God's children amen
and his love cannot be comprehended we
get a glimpse of his love for us when we
look Upon Jesus hanging upon the cross
taking our place in dying for our sins
because of God's love we have the
scripture for God so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish but have everlasting life amen
you I recognize that you're wondering if
your son will be saved and I'm sure that
would be a huge burden upon your heart
and this is because of the love that you
have for your son the Bible says that
God is
love and that he's not willing that any
should be lost so it's hard to
comprehend but we can believe that the
God who created your son loves him even
more than a mother is able to that's in
Isaiah
49:15 of course only God knows a
person's heart
we read that in 1st Samuel 16:7 but the
Lord said unto Samuel look not on his
countenance or on the height of his
stature for the Lord seeth not as man
seeth for man lookth on the outward
appearance but the Lord lookth on the
heart so only God could see what was
going on in your son's heart usually
people that use drugs do so to cover up
or escape from their emotional pain that
they're going through so again Carol we
don't don't know your son's emotional
state but we can rest assured of our
loving Heavenly Father amen who loves
your son and I want to leave you with
this promise from Jeremiah
313 the Lord hath appeared of old unto
me saying I have loved thee with an
everlasting love and therefore with
loving kindness have I draw thee amen
amen and thank you and so sorry thank
you very much Pastor m
Marone all right Pastor James here's
your third
question what do you what do you think
about Deliverance Ministry should we be
involved in this as I read more and more
of God's word I'm coming to the
conclusion that this is not right what
are your thoughts and Bible teachings on
this issue that's was texted to us from
Canada you know this is a very practical
question especially for Ministries in
foreign countries where missionaries can
encounter a much stronger force of
Darkness than we do here in North
America and uh the first thing we need
to recognize just from the Bible Mark
chapter 15 um is that the context of
ministry that Jesus gave to us involves
casting out demons so it says there in
Mark 15 and he said unto them go into
all the world and preach the gospel to
Every Creature he that believes and is
baptized shall be saved but he that
believeth not shall be damned and then
he says this and these signs shall
follow them that believe in my name they
shall cast out devils and speak uh with
new tongues and they shall take up
serpents and if they drink anything
deadly it shall not hurt them and they
shall lay their hands on the sick and
they shall recover so we also understand
that Jesus and his disciples actually
practiced the casting out of evil
spirits we read about that in Matthew
chapter 17 where a multitude was there
and the disciples were praying for a
young man who was divon possessed and
they couldn't could cast him out and
then Jesus comes on the scene and not
only does he cast out the demon but he
tells his disciples the reason you
couldn't cast him out was because this
kind goes out not but by fasting and
prayer and so there's this uh Focus that
Jesus has that that he gives to us he
says hey we need to really fast and pray
when we're dealing with these forces of
Darkness but finally we need to be
cautious uh and not deliberately engage
in casting out demons as a full-time
Ministry or Focus you know yes Jesus
told us we'd be empowered to cast out
evil spirits but it he clearly stated
that as a side note not the central
focus of ministry to the world you know
the Bible talks about a young man who
sought to make this their Ministry and
it ended really badly for them and
that's found in Acts 19: 13- 16 and so
Jesus didn't tell us to go forth and
cast out Devils any more than he told us
to go forth and take up serpents or
drink deadly things Jesus said that
those would be signs that would follow
the preaching of the gospel and they
would indicate its authenticity but they
wouldn't make it authentic you know
authentic Christianity preaches the
gospel to All Nations and while at times
we may need to cast out Devils we may
need to deliver people from uh demonic
possession by praying for them and
interceding for them and fasting and
praying and and we may need to be
yourselves delivered from deadly poisons
or from serpents and we can I can share
experiences about that in the mission
field um we shouldn't make this the
focus of our ministry now there is a
Ministry Adventist Frontier Ministries
Ministry that has some material
available for those who are who are
working in the areas of the world they
work the 1040 window where there's a lot
of satanic manifestations and Demon
demonic possession and uh if this is
something that you're facing I would
recommend contacting Adventist Frontier
Mission they have a actually have a
study on this that you can download uh
free of charge from their website amen
thank you for that answer that's really
good all right sister Shelly here's your
last
question is God a man I went to a Bible
study and one of the members said we do
not know if God is a man or a woman I
know God created man in His image and
Jesus told us to pray Our Father which
art in Heaven I've always believed God
is male that question was texted to us
this is a very interesting question and
we're going to go to the scripture to
find the answer biblical imagery
describing God really serves to
illustrate his relationship with
Humanity rather than Define his Essence
Jesus said in John
4:24 God is spirit and those who worship
Him must Worship in spirit and Truth
he's a spiritual being he is
transcendent um he exists Beyond
physical the physical form and the
Physical Realm so he exists Beyond human
attributes beyond the limitations of
human gender he's invisible not a
physical material nature of man in
Colossians 1:15 it says Jesus is the
image of the
invisible God the firstborn which is
Covenant language for preeminence over
all creation when we think
about the person of the the three
persons of the
godhead they all had mind intellect and
emotions and actions of relationship and
communication so yes in Genesis 1:26 and
27 God said let us make man in our image
according to our likeness this is the
godhead the three talking among
themselves so God created man in his own
image in the image of God he created
them male and female he created them he
created both male and female in His
image with mind and intellect Free Will
emotion moral capacity and he created
them for relationship God revealed
himself to
Mankind in the male form in the Old
Testament and he revealed himself to
mankind certainly as a man in the New
Testament when one of the godhead came
down and became the son of man and so we
see when he became incarnated in the
person of Jesus Christ God chose a male
form approximately 170 references are in
the Bible to God is Father the masculine
pronounce he and him help us to
understand and reflect relational
qualities of God that were associated
with the uh near Ancient the ancient
near East with male
roles but God's qualities are reflected
in both genders amen embodying the love
Justice compassion strength that is
expressed in both men and women the
Bible uses a maternal image of God to
describe his nurturing and compassionate
nature Isaiah
6613 he compare it Compares God to the
Comfort his comfort to that of a mother
Matthew
23:37 Jesus said I wanted to bring you
in oh Jerusalem Jerusalem as a hen
gathers her chicks so here's the bottom
line the
universality and accessibility of God
are not limited by human categories his
love is inclusive his Divine image can
be present by the holy spirit in every
person regardless of gender amen amen
thank you so much sister love that
answer okay pastor morone here's your
final
question can I give myself communion at
home I'm homebound due to disability and
illness that's from Tanya in Louisiana
who texted that to us wow so sorry about
your disability there Tanya you know
Jesus instituted this service after what
we call the Last Supper this was a
Passover meal the very last one that
pointed back to the Israelite
deliverance from Egypt and then forward
to Christ's crucifixion who is the true
Passover Lamb so instead of killing a
lamb to remind us Jesus instituted the
communion service it was to remind us of
Christ sacrific for us in 1 Corinthians
11:26 it says for as often as you eat
this bread and drink this cup you do
show the Lord's death till he come the
bread represents Jesus's broken body and
the wine or grape juice represents his
blood that was shed for us you know God
knows us really well seems like we're
always needing something to remind us
reminders like remember the Sabbath day
to keep it holy was a reminder that he's
our creator as well as Our Redeemer you
know I don't believe we have an example
of someone doing communion by themselves
in the Bible and Jesus does say in
Matthew 18:20 for where two or three are
gathered in my name there I am in the
midst of them and then Hebrews 10:25
says not forsaking the assembling of
ourselves together as the manner of some
is so when I was pastoring we would
often ask our
shuttin uh if they would we could bring
the communion to their house or
sometimes it would be the hospital or
nursing home um so not sure if you
reached out to your church to see if
someone would be willing to do that you
know I don't want you to miss a blessing
a fellowship if you can help it
amen and that said I don't know of any
Scripture that would prohibit you from
remembering Jesus's death through this
service at home you know I'll end with
this scripture and he took bread and
gave thanks and break it and gave unto
them saying this is my body which is
given for you this do in remembrance of
me likewise also the cup after supper
saying this is the New Testament in my
blood which is shed for you that's in
Luke 22 19 and 20 you know I remember
one time I actually did the communion
with someone on FaceTime with my cell
phone so the main thing is remembering
that our loving Savior and his
sacrificial love for us and blessings to
you ton amen amen thank you very much
sir all right Pastor James here's your
final
question what name should we be baptized
in Father Son and Holy Ghost is not a
name that was texted to us from
Pennsylvania thank you for that text
from Pennsylvania you know you pick up
some of the character of a person when
they ask a question and that was a a
very question it's one of those
questions that uh seems to point out a
contradiction uh between verses of the
Bible and it's a question that I've had
to deal with myself as a pastor who
baptizes so let's begin in Matthew 28
and let's read verses 18 and 19 where
this question is centered in
relationship to baptizing it says there
in in Matthew chapter 28 we'll begin
with Verse 18 and Jesus came and he
spake unto them saying all power is
given unto me in heaven and in Earth and
that word power could be translated
Authority some of your translations May
read Authority go ye therefore verse 19
says go ye therefore and teach All
Nations baptizing them in the name of
the father and the Son and the Holy
Ghost there's what we have the name
referred to teaching them to observe all
things whatsoever I have commanded you
and lo I Am With You Always even until
the end of the world Amen now when we
take a look at the Greek we find that
the word for name in the Greek actually
means Authority or character it's not
referring specifically to a name like
John Smith right John Smith was you know
it's just kind of one of those names
that we use Jane Doe John Smith John
Smith actually was a young man I went to
school with years ago we used to call
him Smitty anyway so we're we're
commanded here if we want to get
particular about it really particular
about it we're commanded here to baptize
in the Authority or character of the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit and
not necessarily use a specific name
right so that I think would answer the
question but let's go a little further
here if we need to put a name in the
equation when we baptize we can do this
biblically by looking at this Bible
verse in the book of Acts Acts chapter 2
and verse 38 here's what it says Acts 2
and verse 38 then Peter said unto them
repent and be baptized every one of you
in the name of Jesus Christ
for the remission of sins and you shall
receive the gift of the holy spirit so
now we have a name added to the command
of Christ uh when we place these two
biblical texts together which is what I
do when I baptize people you put them
together we find this phrase I think as
appropriate for those ministers who are
baptizing okay I baptize you in the name
of the Father the Son Jesus Christ and
the holy spirit amen so I really hope
this is helpful for you and for your
church family
uh I recently talked to someone or we
heard from someone recently that this
issue was dividing the whole church we
don't need to divide the church over
this I think God has given us h a very
gracious conclusion we baptize in the
name of the Father the Son Jesus Christ
and the Holy Spirit we've got both those
verses covered and we recognize it's in
the character and authority of God and
not specifically in a name amen amen
thank you very much for that answer very
good I was blessed by this yes a lot of
great
questions that we got the answers from
in God's word you know I hope that
you've been blessed with this as well
and I want to remind you that you can
find answers to these questions on our
website have you heard about it 3abn
Bible anwers.com have you heard of that
website you can check that site out I
encourage you to check it out you can
get answers to questions on the topic of
the Antichrist you can get questions to
ANW to the questions on baptism and
Heaven and the Judgment the second
coming and and much more so check out
3abn Bible
answers.com and if this program was a
been a blessing for to you I encourage
you to share it with someone else
especially if you're watching it on
social media you can click that little
link copy it and paste it and text it to
somebody that could be don't hold that
blessing to yourself and you know what
when you're doing that you are being a
witness you're being a witness for God
and we can do it through social media
there's so much Darkness there in social
media so I encourage you to cast some
light out in there with sharing God's
messages through social media text it to
someone share it on your Facebook share
it on your Twitter or ex share it on
Instagram tons of different ways you can
do that so I encourage you to do that
and then listen we're going to be coming
right back because we've got to talk
with our panelists to get some final
thoughts from them so I want to
encourage you to come back don't go away
we we'll be right back
amen if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible Q QA
[Music]
3abn.org with us the thought that came
to my mind particularly when you were
talking about sharing on the Internet or
Facebook is this when we respond to
anybody's Bible question you've had some
difficult questions talking about
someone who lost their son to a drug
overdose James you've had difficult
questions from people who maybe worked
all their the sabbaths during their life
here's the point please do
what this this these beautiful men do
what we do try to do here answer in a
spirit of Grace in the love of Jesus
Christ don't we will you know you can
never convince somebody how beautiful
the music is by beating them over the
head with the violin you you've got to
you can't convince them of the beauty of
the love of God by beating them over the
head
with the Bible please be gentle and
loving and open to listening as well as
to stating amen amen thank you sister
Pastor morone please yeah you know just
that made me think of where Jesus one
time the disciples wanted to call fire
down from heaven Jesus said you don't
know what
spirit and it's the spirit that's more
powerful than the actual thing that's
coming out of your mouth the spirit all
right thank you sir Pastor James final
thoughts I love that yeah just to build
on that a little bit you know this uh
Psalm 87 it kind of goes back to the
first question that I I answered Psalm
87 uh talks about people from different
backgrounds and that when God judges the
people he considers where we came from I
just want to read a couple verses here
because they're really beautiful Psalm
87 says the lord loves the gates of Zion
more than the Dwellers dwellings of
Jacob glorious things are spoken of thee
Oh city of God I will make mention of
Rahab and Babylon and them that were
born there I will make uh no uh I uh
behold fisa and Tyra Ty and Ethiopia
this man was born there and of Zion it
is said that this man was born in her
and the highest himself shall establish
her and the Lord shall count or consider
when he writes up the people that this
man was born in them or in this man was
born there Sila think about this as so
as well as the singers as the players of
instruments shall be there and my
Springs are in thee so Psalm 87 the
whole Psalm is speaking to the question
will people be saved even though they
didn't know the truth and God will
consider my father-in-law loved this my
wife's uh father loved this this Psalm
because he was brought up in a very dark
and difficult world and it it reminded
him that God considers our backgrounds
and where we came from and and there's
one other verse I want to just throw out
really quickly at Zechariah 13:6 you
know there are going to be people in
heaven who didn't know anything about
Jesus or the cross or the wounds and
Psalm uh Zechariah 13:6 says and one
shall say unto him Jesus what are these
wounds in thine hands and he shall
answer those with which I was wounded in
the house of my friends they're going to
learn in heaven all about Christ and his
great sacrifice amen amen thank you
thank you very much well thank you for
watching I want to encourage you to
share God's word and you can do that
with scripture and here's what a great
scripture song blessed are they that do
his Commandments that they may have
right to the tree of life and may enter
into his gra Gates into the city
Revelation
20214 so hide God's word in your heart
always and be ready to share God bless
[Music]